blackhead podcast special guest in here
representing stockton california
my guy the mexipino pino
yo yo shout out don quay's in the
building man welcome bro how you doing
yo real quick um just shout out what you
got going on like what what what is
going on in your world bro uh just a lot
of music i just dropped the album called
hell of a ride uh just pushing that
right now and just you know getting on
here and just doing my thing what um
you know when if people haven't heard
you if you had to like kind of compare
yourself to some some other you know
some people that they might know like
who are you inspired by like like kind
of what's your vibe
uh i'm inspired by like uh
like the kendricks the yays tyler's
movement right um
i like uh kid cudi and you know pharrell
i grew up on that area right there was
is it like stockton's like a pretty wild
place as far as like
i feel like the biggest artists out of
stockton are kind of known for doing
like street [__] yeah yeah um and you're
kind of are you kind of you feel like
you're bringing some different flavor to
the table yeah definitely i'm not i'm
not in the streets like that i don't
really promote it like that either uh
being from stockton it's like uh i guess
easy to get that little misconception
that it's just fully like that
um but there are definitely some cool
spots and some cool people in there
there's a different agenda for sure
indeed man well look go follow him and
we're gonna have you rap and you pick
this beat so i love the beat choice too
let's get to it come on
[Music]
envisioning the life that i wanted with
god's permission but the devil on my
shoulder keep talking so condescending
he woke up told him get him i got him
now girl ridden some people that grow
distant but now i'm going the distance i
can stare from down there i got a whole
different vision step over like ai for
those in question my bro armed with a
hammer that'll slam you in submission
see i'm the answer like allen i'm valid
anywhere i raise the ball verizon flow
you hit me anywhere y'all got bars but
y'all songs making a hoe scared quit
calling yourself a goat dog you dare yet
perrier water glass filled up with some
motifs [__] the police and anything a
bit of hoe say i should have killed this
beat way sooner but it's okay i don't
know you anything more i'm more
exclusive the dreams turn reality it's
like i dream loosely even through my
darkest times it's translucent i can hop
on anything from trap to jazz fusion hip
hop the rock music slapping you for a
fusion crash course these rappers
actually more amusing i haven't reached
master i'm actually still a student
learning from the l's and the jerry
heller's i'm ruthless and for the record
my projection out of this world if i'm
not the best i'm the best that you've
never heard what's the sheep to a wolf
put you underneath the earth a lot of
rappers jogging in place but i'm a jerk
i didn't have to create this way for
y'all to serve i didn't have to take
this far
i said i didn't have to take it this far
but it worked i earned everything i
never had nobody hand it to me see i'm
the light you a [__] shout out
to me shout out to me made it out the
mud all we got is us double up the paper
folded up gotta switch it up switch
blade tuck for emergency purposes i
gotta stay dangerous for the money they
murder [__] the feature costs are arm
and a leg i should still turn the kids
but rappers don't invest in they sells
they pop percocets life of circus i
ain't working with y'all clowns now i
got pennywise i profit off my pen now i
caught a stride the repetition made me
hand the industry you're pulling sharks
who gonna really sink or swim name a
rapper code is this i tell you why he
isn't him if you living by the sword
then you dying by my pen no cosine
divine timing no denying where i'm at
i'm from the 90 case i had to remind you
where i be at i'm either flying or i'm
frying i'll be higher than chemtrails
when all fails i always bounce back no
matter that outcome the paper keep
coming in the less i weight a lot that's
a blind consequence so be careful who
you let them type of chicks you coming
in these thoughts pass while i have a
couple [__] in my bed i'm not a
sinner a saint a [__] hypocrite i
just love bad [__] foreign names i'll
soon forget i had friends turn to eyes
revealing exactly who they is [__] i'm
hungry for success like i live in
budapest blew the check made two hundred
dollars i just wanna flex so many blue
dollar bills they be thinking i'm a [__]
first rapper out my section of pop
without a set 29 the empire i'm the
latest out the west
and if you press get it off your chest
like a barbell this ain't repetition
it's a flex
and that's a promise not a threat
[__]
okay that's how we come in in 2022 man
yo shout out to my guy don quiz that was
that was dope appreciate the the couple
of o'sheas i caught that that was fire
[__] the pole go for them hey y'all let
them know where they can follow you real
quick man all right don quiz cwt
ig twitter um find me on all music
platforms hell of a ride out now boom
there it is hey i know you just watched
the crazy freestyle appreciate you
watching make sure you subscribe and
make sure
you show some love to our folks at lrg
clothing man listen
i've been [__] with lrg since i was
in high school and they are still doing
their [__] thing all right and i got
something special for you 30 off
your next order at lrg all you got to do
is use the keyword and by keyword i mean
promo code
use the promo code kev 30. that's kev
zero we're gonna put the website right
there you see it right there
l dash r dash g dot com all right we'll
put the website right there cook put the
website right there
save you 30 off one more time use that
promo code kev30 on lrg's website for
your chance well not your chance you'll
actually get 30 off it's not like it's a
[__] contest just use the code and
you got it alright shout out to lrg